we've got news coming in from Bangkok
the taiko capital now the constitutional
court there has ruled that the third
biggest political party must be
disbanded let's go live now to Bangkok
Wayne Hayes our correspondent there he's
actually at Party headquarters now this
is the future forward party Wayne which
did particularly well in the last
election and was a new and exciting
electoral option was it for the people
of Thailand yes it certainly was and we
saw some pretty angry emotional scenes
from these supporters who had gathered
here at the headquarters of the future
forward party as they watched the
livestream come in from the
Constitutional Court and listen to the
judges read out the verdict in this case
and that verdict was as you mentioned
that the party is dissolved and the 11
members of its executive essentially the
core leaders of this political party are
banned from politics for the next 10
years now this all surrounds money that
was given to the party by its
charismatic leader tonight on june rahm
ronk it to basically fund it through the
election campaign in the lead-up to the
election in March last year it totaled
just over six million US dollars now the
party and tonight on said it was alone
and therefore it was exempt from our
political party laws which obviously a
fairly strict around at individual
donations to political parties the
judges and the court disagreed they said
that it was a gift or it was a donation
and therefore it was way above the
permitted amount that an individual can
give to a political party which is just
over three hundred thousand dollars so
certainly as you say this very popular
new face entire politics is now
dissolved and it means to hope for a lot
of people in Thailand has also gone
Wayne hey live in Bangkok thank you